ahora muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña el ex presidente de ecuador
rafael correa quien estuvo al frente del
ejecutivo de este país entre el año 2007
y 2017 señor rafael correa en primer
lugar muchísimas gracias por estar
presente la entrevista de france 24 es
un placer para nosotros no hay placer es
mío no escuché la primera parte luego un
problema técnico pero muchísimas gracias
bueno gracias a usted
buenos días atrás señor correa de la
corte nacional de justicia ecuatoriana
ratificaba no una condena a ocho años de
prisión en su contra por corrupción no y
usted quedó inhabilitado para
presentarse como candidato a la
vicepresidencia del país en los comicios
de febrero de 2021 y también para ocupar
cualquier cargo público como lo afecta a
esta medida señor correo en su vida
también más allá de sus aspiraciones y
de la vida política no
bueno mi aspiración es ver a mi país
fuera de su desarrollo ese mi proyecto
vital y le han hecho mucho daño no en
tres años y me han destruido lo que
construimos constantes fuerza en diez
años en los personales aspiraciones para
mí es estar con mi familia dedicarme a
la academia por eso quise retirarme de
la vida política en todo caso si esto
fuera algo definitivo sería una tragedia
porque habrían condenado un hombre
honesto pero insostenible
ninguna corte internacional va a aceptar
que a un ex presidente se le acuse de
influjo psíquico que las pruebas sean
seis mil dólares que prestó y depositó
en su propia cuenta personal en un banco
del estado predicen que soborno es un
gran montaje y lo que también duele
realmente es que gente inocente yo
escogí la opción política sabía lo que
me enfrentaba cuando quería cambiar un
sistema que ha tenido no he tenido 200
años en ese desarrollo cuando desafía
los poderes que siempre nos han dominado
pero no hay derecho a que se metan con
gente inocente y que la meta empresas
que hagan sufrir tanto a su familia
entonces eso sí duele en el alma duele
profundamente pero esto no se va a
sostener es imposible una cantinflas
tica
decía precisamente no señor correa que
ninguna corte internacional le daría a
esto y trascendió que piensa acudir al
sistema interamericano de justicia así
la causa pasaría no por la comisión
interamericana como una suerte de sala
de admisión para que luego pase a la
corte procesos que suelen durar varios
años no tiene confianza en estas
instancias de toda confianza del pueblo
ecuatoriano cuando cambia la situación
política que vamos a vencer el próximo
en febrero cambiará todo no porque inter
esperamos una justicia porque se dejará
de interferir en la justicia porque
probablemente jueces honestos pero en
las situaciones actuales del país se
necesita juez es heroico porque la
presión mediática política las amenazas
los chantajes han sido brutales y mire
le pongo un ejemplo esto me inhabilita
va a ser es candidato y eso lo que
buscaba usted por su acento escucho que
es argentino pregunté cuánto dura en
argentina un país de mucho mayor
desarrollo relativo que el nuestro que
el ecuador un recurso de casación dura
un año y medio por lo menos acá en
bélgica en europa duró un año en el
ecuador nunca durado menos de cuatro
meses
en mi caso duró 17 días 16 recurso de
casación 17 días no verá ni la forma por
porque están desesperados para tener una
sentencia ejecutoriada antes del 18 de
septiembre cuando era la inscripción de
mi candidatura como vicepresidente
porque lo que buscan es impedir me
participar en las próximas elecciones
señor correa también ha trascendido que
uno de los nombres no que se estarían
evaluando para acompañar al candidato a
la presidencia hablamos de andrés araus
a quien precisamente usted iba a
acompañar no sería su hermana pierina
correa puede usted confirmar esto y de
ser así ella por supuesto cuenta con una
amplia trayectoria en el terreno
político pero el peso del apellido
correa influye quizás a la hora de
considerar su candidatura por supuesto
mire pirena tiene sus méritos propios
por el primer opositor eso soy yo mismo
porque no me gusta siempre combatido a
las negativas en política pero no nos
dejan salida si me elimina a mí la
papeleta eliminaron el partido político
tenemos que que competir con participar
compartido prestado empezar de nuevo a
posicionar el número participamos con
lista 1 han suprimido ese partido y
tenemos que no hemos inscrito o estamos
participando con lista 1
nos queda que poner gente que la
identifiquen con uno para que tenga
información el electorado pero no
personal yo soy el primer opositor de
que mi hermana me reemplace no porque le
falten méritos sino que no siempre he
estado contra las dinastías políticas y
no me gusta pese a las circunstancias
tan extremas que no han hecho vivir caer
en lo mismo que he combatido ahora señor
coreadas una habilitación no para
ejercer cargos públicos llegó
precisamente prácticamente al unísono
con la noticia de que el ex presidente
de bolivia hablamos por supuesto de evo
morales no podría postularse al senado
en los comicios del próximo 18 de
octubre precisamente usted y evo
morales- formaron parte de aquel ciclo
de gobierno progresista en américa
latina' a comienzos de los años 2000
junto a néstor kirchner en argentina
luego cristina kirchner cristina
fernández mejor dicho lula da silva en
brasil
pepe mujica en uruguay entre otros fue
un periodo de cierta sintonía no en el
que es importante impulsaron por ejemplo
organismos como la unasur la unión
suramericana de naciones muchos
analistas ven en el momento actual
de crisis del multilateralismo coincide
usted como analiza el escenario de
américa latina hoy totalmente y no sólo
escenario américa latina del mundo
entero yo creo que no sólo tenemos
retroceso democrático sino civilizatorio
surgen grupos extremistas fanáticos
nacionalistas neo fascistas no sólo en
américa latina en todo el mundo cuál es
la gran diferencia yo viví europa acá
esos grupos están controlados reprimidos
limitados por algo que se llama estado
derecho es una parte fundamental es un
sistema de justicia independiente
profesional algo ético transparente
capaz
pero además hay otro poder muy
importante para contener esos extremos
una prensa mínimamente profesional y
ética eso no existe en américa latina
han destrozado el estado derecho hay una
doble moral impresionante la oea fíjense
cuando le conviene pues hasta promueve
golpes de estado pero se hace la vista
gorda ante el rompimiento constitucional
en el ecuador las represiones en chile
en colombia es la propia bolivia no y la
prensa latinoamericana de ser de las
peores del mundo
ahora con estos grupos para que terminen
con un aire progresista y luego también
los critiquen una vez que hayan cumplido
ya su papel esto es la gran diferencia
yo creo que hay una crisis civilizatoria
a nivel mundial y en américa latina
sobre todo en sudamérica
te hablo de la época de oro américa
latina 2000 2014
repleta gobiernos progresistas que
cambiaron la historia pero no nos lo
perdonan a las élites por primera en la
vida no había verdadera separación de
poder porque el poder económico privado
el poder de los negocios el poder social
no controlaba el estado había un estado
gobernado para el bien común y eso no
nos lo perdonan entonces el nuevo plan
condor para tratar de eliminar ya no con
la represión con la desaparición con la
tortura a los años 70 a los dirigentes
progresistas sino por medio del loser la
judicialización de la política matando
su reputación condenando de los
titulares los medios y jueces corruptos
cobardes oportunistas tan sólo copian lo
que dicen los titulares eso sí es una
estrategia regional lo mismo la persona
lula a christina a evo a mi
vicepresidente a quien le habla etcétera
y qué cambios cree que deberían
producirse para revertir esta situación
que usted caracteriza de esta manera
usted lo ha dicho hay que reconstruirse
multilateral multilateralismo con una
sola moral no con doble moral no con
esta oea que siempre ha sido ministro
las colonias problemas que nunca de las
colonias de eeuu como francia tiene el
ministerio de ultramar no para américa
su colonia la martinica guadalupe la
isla de la reunión etcétera entonces
debemos reconstruir se multiplica
multilateralismo debemos superar la
indiferencia porque lastimosamente en
nuestro país en las contradicciones son
tan graves que cuando usted quiera
cambiar algo tendrá que esta oligarquía
con su poder mediático super social
súper económico su poder militar súper
hasta religioso a tratar de aplastar
cualquier intento el cambio aplastar a
los que osaron desafiar el sistema para
eso se necesita un respaldo
internacional sobre todo los países
desarrollados que ya tienen sistemas que
le han dado razonable buen nivel de vida
a todas ya todos tiene en este momento
una gran indiferencia por ejemplo en
europa lo único que sí está en la gente
venezuela y mine es es importante lo que
ocurrió conmigo un ex presidente 32
penales sentenciado por influjo
psíquicos lejos
sentencia no porque no tiene ninguna
prueba con un recurso de casación
resulta en 17 día laborable sino ocurrió
en venezuela ser un escándalo mundial
entonces una doble moral terrible como
le decía hay un retroceso civilizatorio
y la respuesta a estas contradicciones
que van a ser habiendo américa latina
con usted trate de cambiar algo no es
por gusto estamos 200 años de su
desarrollo por la clase de élites y
poderes que no han dominado desafiar
esos poderes aún no les pone a todos
pero para eso se necesita el respaldo de
una comuna internacional honesta con una
sola moral realmente comprometida con la
democracia los derechos humanos el
estado derecho la justicia la equidad en
caso de ganar
andrés aragón no quien iba a ser su
compañero de fórmula- bueno él continúa
no en la carrera hacia la presidencia
cuál podría ser señor correa su futuro
en la política y también en la justicia
ecuatoriana y evaluando un escenario en
el que se ha derrotado no que podría
suceder en este caso contrario
santiago y mi futuro político créanme
que lo que menos me interesa estoy aquí
por futuro político estoy por servir a
mi patria y de donde esté la serviré de
la academia si me llaman de nuevo para
el servicio público pero nunca me
interesado en lo personal el poder un
puesto etcétera sino ver a mi patria
fuera del subdesarrollo sobre los
procesos oficiales esto no va a aguantar
l
en el juicio la historia ya en el
presente nadie cree en este juicio en
ecuador pues esto está aumentado nuestro
apoyo popular y a nivel internacional no
va aguantar el menor escrutinio mire no
sé si te conoce que yo tengo de prisión
por dos casos este caso sobornos después
todo en tiempo récord donde me acusan de
walle el procesado rafael correa delgado
ejerció sus funciones como presidente
constitucional de la república del
ecuador- 2007 2017 con un poder total
concentrar en sus manos a manera un
autócrata
esto es controlando la 5 funciona el
estado ecuatoriano ejecutiva legislativa
judicial electoral y transparencia esto
latinoamericana latinoamericano el mundo
no es una proclama política un grupo
opositor es la sentencia de jueces que
fuese imparcial y monte mismo
se cambió el 60 los jueces de la corte
nacional son jueces temporales nombrados
a dedo que tienen el requisito
indispensable ser anti correcta eso no
lo sabe el mundo no que lo sepan luego
dice no la prueba evacuada en los 10 se
juicio resulta incontrovertible para
determinar que el procesado rafael
correa delgado hizo surgir sobre un
grupo de personas específicamente sobre
unos funcionarios públicos de su entera
confianza mediante un influjo psíquico
la resolución de realizar el injusto el
cohecho no habido cohecho en un invento
voy a montar pero como tampoco tienen
ninguna prueba contra mí y te dicen que
es por medio influjo psíquico que yo
dirijo una organización para recibir
coche ponen cosas abiertamente falsas
por ejemplo rafael correa delgado y
jorge glas espinel ministro presidente
quienes dirigían el sistema de
contratación pública el ecuador el
presidente lea la constitución no dirige
el sistema contratación pública para
crear la narrativa el muñeco no y
después fíjense por favor es un poquito
de paciencia que éste fundamental este
tribunal de primer nivel estima
indispensable referirse al menos a
cuatro premisas ciertas y probadas
que el procesado rafael correa delgado
exigió la entrega dinero ilícito para sí
misma y dicen se fregó ahí está la
prueba
fruto de los sobornos tan es así que en
franco ejercicio su liderazgo dentro del
entarimado de corrupción recibió el
depósito ahí está la prueba contundente
un millón de dólares en bahamas recibe
el depósito de seis mil dólares en su
cuenta personal que le mantenía el banco
del pacífico que el banco del pacífico
un banco el estado en un préstamo del
propio fondo que nosotros creamos en la
presidencia a nuestro bolsillo la caja
común que hace en la oficina que me
prestaron porque estaba sobre girado de
la playa hasta el último centavo pero en
el montaje lo incluyeron como soborno
contra esto patria grande contra estos
mundos que estamos luchando esto no se
va a sostener el tiempo y no se suele
saber que el otro el otro desde resto
porque me acusan de un secuestro si
contra un supuesto opositor que en
verdad un delincuente prófugo me acusó
un policía que ni conozco diciendo clave
llamó por teléfono ordena el secuestro y
no tiene por aborto el teléfono bueno
ese policía ya buscó asilo en oriente y
medio que todo es un montaje caso
político que lo llamaron para amenazarlo
o te mandamos nueve años presos o acusas
a correr a involucrar la correa
ni siquiera lo ha publicado la prensa
nacional esto se va derrumbando poco a
poco miren lo van a vencer e imposible
que venza la verdad prevalecerá lo que
moleste indigna y duele el daño que
causan el tiempo que hacen perder y las
vidas inocentes que están destruyendo
señor rafael correa- muchísimas gracias
por estos minutos de enfrentas 24 ha
sido un placer dialogar con usted
gracias a usted de santiago un fuerte
abrazo gracias a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
[Música]
y